a forest fire that ignited after days of
record-breaking temperatures has
destroyed most of litton
a small town in central british columbia
this week litton broke canada's all-time
hottest temperature record
three times hitting nearly 50 degrees
celsius on tuesday
local media are reporting that a couple
in their 60s have died due to the fire
many others are missing and more than a
thousand people have evacuated their
homes
the world has heard about litten british
columbia which burned
almost essentially to the ground and
there's been multiple fatalities
reported there and other people
not accounted for some people are having
to go two to three hours away just to
get
uh check in with emergency social
services
so this is something that we've never
seen before in this province or
really in this country anywhere more
than 170 wildfires are burning across
british columbia and western alberta
they're fueled by a record-breaking heat
wave that in turn
led to more than 700 000 lightning
strikes on wednesday and thursday
up tenfold from a year ago health
officials in british columbia say more
than 700 deaths have been reported in
the past week
nearly three times the usual number the
heat wave has also resulted in a rising
death toll in the northwestern united
states
most people don't think about heat as a
killer and it is
and we know that the numbers are fairly
high
certainly the event we've seen we're
going to see excess deaths
a lot more than we should have because
all of those deaths could have been
prevented
so we have to raise that awareness in
oregon governor kate brown has declared
a state of emergency
and in the city of portland the fire
department has banned the use of
fireworks for the fourth of july weekend
canada's forest fire season usually
starts in late july
but with more warm weather forecast over
the next few days
the military is on standby to help
evacuate more towns
victoria gate and b al jazeera